let's get caught up on where we are with
the democratic presidential primary
Hillary Clinton Bernie Sanders Hillary
Clinton has a very large lead nationally
in the Democratic primary but according
to a new Quinnipiac poll Bernie Sanders
is still faring better in hypothetical
matchups against some of the more likely
Republican presidential candidates so
nationally first Hillary Clinton
currently leading Bernie Sanders by an
average of about fifty nine to thirty or
about 29 points nationally however we
have this new poll from Quinnipiac
University which compares Hillary
Clinton and Bernie Sanders to the for uh
more likely Republican presidential
candidates let's take a look at this
louis against uh or where do we want to
start comparing to ted cruz first if I
may Hillary Clinton leads Ted Cruz by
five points in a hypothetical matchup
compared to Bernie Sanders who leads Ted
Cruz by 10 points in a hypothetical
matchup Hillary Clinton leads Donald
Trump by six points compared to Bernie
who leads Donald Trump by eight points
in hypothetical matchups and Hillary
Clinton leads ben Carson by three points
compared to Bernie Sanders is six point
lead and lastly both Hillary and Bernie
lead Marco Rubio by one point so this
supports a couple of things number one
many of these are sort of within the
margin of error which suggests that
actually there is not a drastic
difference in many cases with regard to
Hillary versus Bernie against the major
candidates but it also supports an idea
that I'm increasingly thinking is is the
right up sort of path which is that
Marco Rubio may be the strongest
Republican candidate nationally and we
see that Hillary and Bernie both have
the smallest lead against Marco Rubio
and that Marco Rubio has been surging
within the Republican primary as well I
think Rubio is going to be a contender
here on the Republican side yeah well
III hope so because he's the least crazy
in many ways in many ways and so that's
what we said to begin with whoa that we
thought that Bush was too seems Bush
doesn't have a chance of he's kinda out
of
picture armor yeah Rubio at least Dave I
don't know if you saw that commercial
pays at least he can catch and throw
football yes oh definitely I kinda like
that and we know that you know John
Kerry was just killed for once where he
he yet sort of juggled football that was
thrown to him yeah on the Republican
side dot according to the same
Quinnipiac poll and this is not the
average of all polls Donald Trump is in
the lead with about twenty seven percent
support Marco Rubio in second place at
seventeen percent ted cruz and ben
Carson tied at sixteen percent in an
average of national polls it is still
Trump and Carson so we may be starting
to see uh ben Carson fall out of favor
and Marco Rubio fall into favor this is
only one poll however this particular
pole does look pretty good i looked at
the party identification I looked at
cell phone versus landline phone I
looked at racial demographics it seemed
like a pretty good poll overall uh and
what may be going on in part is that the
front-runner even though they may do
well with regard to favorability the
more known they are the more
unfavorability they will have merely
because some people will see the
front-runner and say oh now that I know
more about them I don't like them so to
sum up Bernie Sanders slightly more
electable than Hillary Clinton versus
the hypothetical Republicans although
within the margin of error against many
of those candidates